[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro 2 de
paf qui sera entièrement entièrement
consacré une ville qui est sous les feux
de l'actualité c'est la ville de trappes
pour des bonnes ou des mauvaises raisons
on va on va en parler avec deux invités
vous savez quand on parle de cette ville
on parle souvent avec des préjugés ou
avec des arrière pensées politiques ou
alors pour faire du sensationnalisme
quand jean marc morandini par exemple va
dans une ville c'est plutôt pour faire
du spectacle pour sa part des fours des
choses va nous allons essayer de faire
le contraire on va aborder le fond des
choses avec des invités qui sont des
habitants de trappes pour la plupart et
qui sont aussi des acteurs de cette
ville et à travers leur mission ou leur
association
valérie rodrigues bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la directrice des admissions
populaire de trappes qui est une
organisation d'obédience protestante et
vous aurez intervenait notamment pour
l'alphabétisation d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui arrivent à la trappe
marie-laure ce galeux bonjour vous avez
été enseignante leur enseignante au
lycée le lycée voilà vous étudié la
philosophie à ses professeurs de
philosophie avant didier mais avant
didier lenoir et vous êtes vous êtes la
présidente d'une association qui
s'appelle dire et agir secteu mans
peretti levier bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le curé de la ville de trappes alors la
communauté catholique c'est pas la
communauté majoritaire attrape un ce
sont les musulmans mais c'est d'une
canne ou menotté qui est très vivante
j'ai la chance d'être curé d'une fait
d'une communauté vivant de 500 600
personnes à peu près qui viennent de
nombreux pays différents qui ceux qui se
rassemblent et je pense qu'ils tentent
de vivre une aventure de de paix pour
eux et puis ensuite pour la vigne voilà
au service de la ville également nos
services de la ville et et en
collaboration avec notre dialogue
par les dialogues assez assez simple
avec eux tous ceux qui vivent aussi dans
cette ville alors avec nous en
visionnage à one bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la pression des mamours dekker
maman du coeur c'est une association qui
agit aussi de manière sociale et
notamment
vous avez une action très très fortes à
l'égard des familles dos des enfants
étaient partis en syrie sont morts
souvent en syrie et vous devant m'en
parler hein et puis et puis nouradine
hague
bonjour vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
journée c'est notamment la marmite fm et
vous êtes vous connaissez très bien la
ville de trappes donc votre regard va
être très précieux dans cette émission
alors c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé
de trappes jeudi cessé depuis
depuis quelques semaines il s'est tu
cette affaire le maire quand on parle de
trappes on en parle souvent comme d'un
territoire un peu particulier de la
république
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
choquent ou c'est quelque chose que vous
comprenez je vais commencer par vous
l'avez rodriguez parce que vous détend
on parle souvent de trappes quand ça va
mal et jamais pour ça va bien ah oui
c'est vrai moi je en fait j'ai adopté
cette ville puisque je suis pas venu
vous amener l'eau depuis dix ans après
voilà je suis là depuis dix ans donc je
suis pas née atteint donc je pense que
j'ai peut-être un regard plus objectif
et sans doute moins viscéral
mais en tout cas moi je suis là depuis
une dizaine d'années et je trouve que
c'est une ville très attachante
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
de souci je pense qu'on en est tous
conscients et personne ne dira le
contraire
mais c'est une ville qui est très
attachante peut-être plus que d'autres
villes de
de la même taille ailleurs en france
dans lesquels j'ai pu j'ai pu vivre
parce qu'il ya une chaleur humaine je
trouve qu'on retrouve pas nécessairement
dans d'autres dans d'autres villes de
france
cela dit l'image de trappes oui elle est
allée elle n'est pas forcément très
positive moi quand j'ai rencontré le
papa de mes enfants
oui vous à paris déposer vous dire il
m'a pas dit qu'il habitait trappe il m'a
dit qu'il habitait à saint quentin en
yvelines est effectivement parce que
parce qu'il ya cette image là quand j'ai
su que c'était trappe
sur le moment j'ai dit ben non moi je ne
mets pas les pieds à trappes c'est pas
possible
quelle image vous aviez l'image que les
médias en donne c'est à dire l'image
d'une ville
d'une ville où la drogue règne l'image
d'une ville où il ya de la violence
l'image d'une ville où les islamistes
ont pris le pouvoir voilà c'était
l'image que j'avais moi il ya déjà dix
ans et quand je suis arrivé à trappes
j'ai constaté que cette image là bas
c'était pas c'était pas l'image de cette
ville
ces débats la réalité c'était pas la
réalité pardon et
et je pense que comme dans tous les
sommets comme vous le dites quand même
si on va en reparler mais même si des
choses existe bien sûr toutes les villes
de france
il ya déjà des choses très positives ya
des choses moins positive
moi c'est l'image que les journalistes
en donne ça me fait penser aux gens
qu'ils qui passe quinze jours en avant
au mali et qui disent j'ai fait
l'afrique voilà c'est exactement la même
chose on passe dans la rue jean jaurès
léon koné trappe mais je pense qu'une
ville ça se connaît comme une personne
finalement il faut y passer du temps il
faut y passer beaucoup de temps et c'est
pas ce que font la majorité des
journalistes malheureusement on en a vu
un exemple encore vendredi
on s'est promené dans trappe en a vu
trois personnes sur le marché mais on
connaît pas la ville de jeu on n'est pas
la ville et c'est ça qui est gênant
finalement c'est que on en donne une
image qui est qui et pas du tout qui est
pas du tout la réalité
n'at il a justement sur sur cette image
de trappes à l'heure des médiums jusqu'à
préciser c'est une association c'est
avant tout la citoyenneté avec adultes
et jeunes dans les quartiers de trappes
que j'ai une facilité à les couples
actifs c'est ce qu'il faut que je je je
propose un lieu d'écouté pour ces mamans
jeu ce que je veux dire voilà c'est pas
je travaille pas que contre la
radicalisation les radicalité c'est un
symptôme qu'on attrape certes mais c'est
quelque chose en plus mais c'est pas ma
priorité c'est à dire que j'ai de la
chance qu'elle me fasse confiance j'ai
cette science qu'elle me fasse confiance
parce que c'est très difficile pour elle
de trouver un endroit parce qu'elles
font confiance je suis aussi la
vice-présidente ex-vice-présidente de
parole à coeur ouvert
association avec laquelle j'étais avec
marie-laure mais c'est juste pour
revenir sur run sur sa ce pas qu'on me
montre que pour je travaille pas que
avec les mamans dont les enfants sont
notamment un notamment cette transaction
c'est à dire c'est que voilà je connais
bien valérie je connais bien pu arrêter
à ce que l'on travaille tout sans rien
on aime tous notre ville et pour moi est
là elle a des difficultés qui sont réels
et les difficultés sont faits à parce
qu'on est beaucoup d'immigrés et c'est
vrai que du coup on est beaucoup de
musulmans et qu'un musulman n'est jamais
le même un autre musulman date ne trie
pas dire que même mon fils
n'a pas la même vision de l'islam que
moi donc le fait qu'on soit différent
avec des visions différentes
c'est ce qui fait la difficulté en fait
c'est prendre le temps de s'accepter
entre nous c'est comme ça je m'en dire
que moi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
représente la communauté musulmane
je présente pas les trappistes je ne
représente que ma vision à moi et une
fois que sais-je menaçant faisait je
pense qu'on pourrait plus facilement
comprendre les choses vous avez bien
fait de le risque chacun parle en ce
moment et c'est vrai vous avez raison de
dire que vous connaissez tous ceux
perrier vous êtes vous êtes curette de
trappes depuis quand c'est la sixième
année viendra près et vous étiez ou
avant l'art par avant j'étais à houilles
carrières sur seine
belga notre un autre paysage du
département et puis évidemment
auparavant avant que la ville pendant
cinq ans d'accord à huy qu'aider est là
quand on vous a proposé trapèze qu est
ce que vous aviez l'image par exemple
que valérie andré gaz pouvait savoir
qu'elle dit elle venait du sud ouest
peut-être que connaissiez départements
vous verrez je connaissais le
département je connaissais pas presque
pas trappe ans en arrivant comme comme
curé de cette ville de l'intérieur de
l'église
nos quartiers populaires sartrouville
mantes-la-jolie les mureaux trappe ont
une belle réputation parce que ce qui
s'y vit dans la communauté chrétienne
relève un peu d'une aventure est depuis
de nombreuses années d'une aventure
assez heureuse et cette fierté c'est
celle moi je pense aussi beaucoup de
paroissiens qui sont heureux de vivre
les uns après les autres les uns avec
les autres de bâtir la paix il ya une
vraie joie et moi personnellement je me
disais ça hier soir peut-être ce qui me
frappe le plus dans cette paroisse c'est
la dignité des habitants mots je suis
assez stupéfait
on se lève tôt on travaille on essaie
d'éduquer le mieux possible ses enfants
avant beaucoup de choses qui peuvent
être dit sur cette ville c'est plutôt ça
qui me vient la joie la dignité la
dignité des personnes qui habitent et
j'ai pas envie d'entendre exactement
l'image qu'on en donne c'est pas ça qui
me vient d'abord voilà je vois d'aider
des familles qui essaye de faire le
mieux possible la vie est pas facile
c'est pas des lieux où tout est simple
il ya de la précarité il ya du voyage on
n'est pas forcément nés en france
et pourtant et pourtant là je vois
l'emporter si souvent si souvent voilà
donc lorsqu'on m'a dit tu pars attrape
le premier sentiment c'était d'abord une
très grande joie de très grandes depuis
six ans objectivement elle est restée
sept cette voie là josé mari l'aurait il
n'aura nouradine peut-être justement sur
ce sur l'animal en vain si on écoute de
valérie rodriguez ou le père y est on a
l'impression que haggaï skis sans doute
rien il ya une joie et une force une
force d habitants d une force d
associations mais il ya aussi des papes
peut-être des problèmes
merci déjà pour l'invitation au patrice
alors je ne suis pas un spécialiste de
la ville de trappes a certes j'ai grandi
j'ai travaillé depuis depuis plus de 15
ans maintenant
mais voilà moi j'apporte également un
point de vue journalistique avec les
personnes qui sont autour du plateau et
que je connais tout ça c'est
personnellement aidé c'est une petite
ville où le dire ensuite j'aimerais
revenir sur l'image d'avoir patrice
parce que à la fin des années 80 - gt gt
petits collégiens et je n'ai pas j'ai
fait une partie du collège en dehors des
trappes dans une fille qui s'appelle
fond il fleurit et dès que mes camarades
de classe apprenait que je venais de
trappes
il y avait une sorte de crainte mélangé
à de la fascination sur une ville un
petit peu fantasmes alors moi je reviens
je rejoins tout à fait ce qui a été dit
recéler la majeure partie des
témoignages que je recueille rejoint ce
qu'a dit le père guy skis a dit valérie
ce qu'a dit également leïla on va voir
également ce qu'en dit marie-laure d'une
ville dont à laquelle on s'attache en
fait il ya un fort sentiment
d'attachement même pour les personnes
qui ont quitté cette ville j'en ai revus
et qui les ont kg quitté depuis 20-30
ans même pour celles qui l'ont été parce
qu'il y avait des soucis notamment je
pense qu on leur parlera tout à l'heure
avec la radicalisation de changement que
ça opéré dans cette ville mais c'est
vrai que globalement les
les personnes mortes car garde une image
positive de cette ville après sur les
choses qui vont pas je sais pas si on
commence maintenant
d'ici là les alizés puis on va après ce
but donna la parole à marie laure alors
ce qui est très important de signaler
pascal à mon humble avis c'est la
situation d'abord sociale de la ville de
trappes un taux de chômage qui est
quasiment le double du niveau national
dans certaines tranches d'âge et je
pense que c'est de là que tout part
puisqu'on peut faire tous les discours
qu'on veut on peut palabrer pendant des
heures et des heures tant que les
personnes ne sont pas capables le père
client quitte à leur a parlé dignité
tant que les gens ne sont pas capables
de gagner leur pain dans la dignité et
de gagner et de gagner leur vie dans des
conditions dignes
c'est difficile après puisque ça devient
un terreau fertile à tous les
extrémismes et c'est justement un des
problèmes majeurs dans les années 80
c'était plus la drogue drogues dures et
puis voilà dans les années récentes dans
les 15 dernières années
à peu près une 15 21 ardennes c'est vrai
que c'est la radicalisation qui qui
après le pas avec des personnalités qui
était charismatique sur la ville de
trappes qui était lié à des réseaux à
des réseaux très dur interréseaux
terroristes notamment et qui ont
commencé à faire un travail de sape sur
toute la ville et c'est à partir de là
[Musique]
on se pose même des questions se posent
même des questions puisque quand on
refait toute cette histoire on se dit
mais comment at on pu laisser faire
presque à ciel ouvert voilà ce travail
de saint pierre a ensuite mené dans les
années 2015 2016 à ce que l'on sait et
notamment avec des départs sur sur les
terrains irak aux syriens
je veux pas monopoliser la parole
pendant mais c'est triste et c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites là
marie-laure ce gars là justement
vous avez publié un communiqué de votre
association d'y réagir dont le titre est
celui ci a trap aussi le danger de
l'islamisme est un fléau
donc il ya quand même cette réalité là
et vous parlez de la sphère le maire
évidemment il ya quand même ses traites
réalité là mais je ne veux pas paraître
pour celles n'en parle mais qu'est ce
que ce que me dit elias est modérée et
libérale justement ce dont parlait
d'abord les conditions sociales dont
parle nouradine et dont parle aussi
etienne sont évidemment une d une des
causes de la filtration de l'islamisme
parce que je crois qu'il faut parler
d'islamisme même si le mot est difficile
et surtout prendre le temps de le
distinguer de l'islam puisque
malheureusement la confusion est
complètement colossal alors moi je suis
invité je ne sais pas à quelle pour
quelles raisons mais je dirais parce que
j'ai été moi-même donc professeur de
philosophie au lycée et je tiens à le
dire puisque moi j'ai vu dès les années
95 le 8 c'est une vieille histoire
c'est une vieille histoire voilà j'ai vu
dès les années 95 le on parlait pas
d'islamisme on se parlait plutôt de
fondamentalisme j'expliquais que la
religion il ya ya la façon de l'avoir
selon l'esprit et selon la lettre
et malheureusement la lettre semblait
l'emporter sur l'esprit par exemple
j'avais des mes cours interrompus parce
que on me disait mais il paraît que vous
êtes athée et madame j'ai parlé de tout
autre chose
mais madame comment c'est possible je
l'homosexualité j'en parlais forcément
quand on parle de fraude ça nous arrive
on me disait mais madame ça vient du
démon alors c'est vrai que j'avais que
quelques élèves qui étaient comme ça
mais ces élèves là pour moi enseigné la
philosophie il ya quelque chose de
commun avec mon voisin prêtre c'est
l'idée en tous les cas que l'esprit
critique apprentissage du doubs de
l'autonomie c'est pour tout le monde
donc ça c'est ma personnalité c'est à
dire qu'elle avait deux ou trois dans
mes classes qui avec lesquels je ne
pouvais pas discuter se dit
ce que dit didier lemaire aujourd'hui
non pas au niveau de deux ou trois
élèves
mais il arrive à dire une moitié de
classe par exemple un mois deux ou trois
c'était déjà trop et c'est vrai que j'ai
arrêté de travailler en plein vol je
dirais parce que j'ai eu
j'ai été mise en examen pour agir par
voie de presse on vers un groupe pour
son appartenance religieuse parce que
j'avais participé à un entretien dans le
monde de l'éducation
bon je veux pas faire l'ancienne
combattante c'est pas le duel c'est vrai
à l'époque ça se passait mais ça s'est
passé la récession voilà exactement
c'est que à l'époque on aller jusqu'au
tribunal finalement on n'a pas été
jusqu'au tribunal
mais c'était tout comme parce qu'on
était chauffée à blanc et donc on aurait
presque préféré
bon voilà donc aujourd'hui ça passe par
les réseaux sociaux donc moi je voudrais
dire tout mon soutien vis-à-vis de
didier lemaire même si le même si j'y
tiens il ne connaît pas la réalité
trappistes tels que moi j'ai pu la
connaître par la suite ayant arrêté de
travailler à 50 ans contre mon gré
puisque j'étais membre responsable
associative donc entre autres de médiane
par exemple qui est une association donc
d'éducateurs les éducateurs reviennent à
trappes d'ailleurs grâce à à lire rabais
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas se
contenter de dire untel et blanc l'autre
enfin si le planning et voilà c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça c'est sa
défense et le sens de ce débat
aujourd'hui enfin je pense c'est de
montrer que les choses sont compliquées
compliqué que l'on ne peut pas se
contenter abat un tel didier lemaire il
parle dans un journal de droite ou une
télé de droite donc il est fasciste
on entend des choses comme ça donc c'est
ridicule moi je sais que je fais
attention à qui je parle parce que j'ai
pas envie d'être le rappelle à l'époque
j'avais envie que comme interview dans
paris match c'est mon choix mais mais
cela dit c'est pas parce que j'aurais
parlé dans paris match que j'étais
d'accord les émirats comme exemple c'est
à dire arrêtons de carrie simplifier le
met les gens dans des étiquettes c'est
tellement commode et ça évite de
réfléchir c'est ce que j'appelle et là
on rejoint la philo c'est combattre les
pensées courte
oui complètement d'accord avec ça je
crois que le problème aujourd'hui des
réseaux sociaux et des médias d'ailleurs
c'est que l'on ne sait pas fonction la
simplification se balancent des trucs à
la figure t de droite et de gauche
s'étaient islamistes août et sans
vraiment décortiquer ce qui se passe sur
le terrain et sans
sans le faire avec une certaine
intelligence finalement je crois qu'il
faut aussi dépasser
ce que ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire l'image moi j'ai dans
l'association à laquelle je travaille
deux mamans qui sont habillés tout en
noir avec voilà je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle exactement hidjab et quand je
les ai vus arriver dans l'association je
me suis dit effectivement la première la
première pensée que j'ai eu c'est
effectivement bah voilà elles seront
sans doute radical et il s'avère que pas
du tout donc encore une fois la bible
j'en ai discuté avec elle ce sont des
femmes très pieuse mais pas du tout
radical ni radicaliser ses des femmes
merveilleuses d'ailleurs avec lesquels
maintenant j'ai une relation presque
amicales et c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'on peut pas connaître ni une ville ni
une personne d'ailleurs en cinq minutes
c'est pas possible
déjà si on n'y vit pas moi je vis
attraper c'est un choix que j'ai fait
j'aurais pu aller vivre ailleurs je suis
à trappes depuis une dizaine d'années
c'est vraiment un choix et je pense
qu'on peut pas connaître une ville de
l'intérieur si on n'y habitent pas déjà
et puis si on regarde pas les choses
avec intelligence et avec finesse et
sans caricaturer une femme voilée s'est
pas forcément c'est pas forcément une
femme qui est radicalisée c'est une
femme qui est peut-être tout simplement
pieuse voilà oui mais elle peut être
aussi radicaliser ses adversaires de fil
ou est ce qu'il ya eu aussi l'image de
la femme qui n'ont qui peut être
atteinte en dehors de en dehors de la
religion je la partage
je pense que quand c'est un choix 7e
chose quand s'est imposée c'est autre
chose est effectivement et je pense 4 ap
il ya des femmes à qui on impose le
voile j'en suis persuadé il faut pas non
plus regarder la réalité en se disant
que trappe c'est une ville de bisounours
c'est pas non plus un bon voilà je pense
que
enfin moi je pense que j'ai un peu de
recul et un regard assez objectif
puisque je quelque part je viens de
l'extérieur aux synergies j'ai pas vécu
toute mon enfance ici j'ai vécu dans une
ville qui ressort à bordeaux qui
ressemblait pas du tout à trappes
voilà donc je pense que faut vraiment
regarder les choses avec finesse ce que
ne font pas les médias au jour que ne
peut pas faire les médias parce qu'ils
intéressent voilà à autre chose de
spectaculaire et c'est toujours très
racoleur et ce qui est dommage et est ce
que dit un atelier justement ce que
disait marie laure segal on a
l'impression avec des points de vue très
différents
celui de monsieur le maire mais d'autres
totalement différent du sien c'est des
gens qui en font aiment leur ville
c'est avec des avec des points de vue
différents et d'aider des analyses
différentes
c'est sûr je pense que moi ça me frappe
un peu enfin voilà sur ses choix il ya
un attachement à cette ville parce que
si c'est une ville si deux des fils
c'est aussi parce que tout est pas
évident qu'on a envie de qu'on a envie
de se remonter les manches et qu'elle
ait de mieux en mieux
moi personnellement ce que je trouve
complexe depuis huit jours où on a
l'impression d'être dans une lessiveuse
mais dit rien il échappe un peu puis les
enjeux sont parfois au delà de ce qu'on
est en train de vivre au quotidien
c'est d'avoir l'impression qu'il n'ya
pas d' espace entre celui qui sera taxé
d' angélisme et celui qui sera taxée de
stigmatisation pilori et alors elle est
où la voix soit on est naïf soit on est
une personne radicale aux mots durs pour
moi je pense qu'il manque un troisième
terme et le troisième terme peut-être
c'est ça justement qui fait que nous
aimons cette ville chacun y btan
peut-être des choses différentes
derrière c'est le désir d'espérer pour
cette ville parce que je crois que ne
plus espérer pour une communauté humaine
c'est la flinguer cc c'est terrible moi
je veux vraiment je j'entends et
j'écoute avec attention la crédibilité
d'un homme qui a enseigné 20 ans en soit
20 ans et berlin sont le souk rayonnante
parole qui est néanmoins j'avoue
qu'intérieurement et moi mais surtout
tout ce qui m'entoure ont été
extrêmement blessée par une formule
peut-être qui lui a échappé
mais je pense qu'ils ne peut pas sortir
qu'il peut pas sortir elle l épilogue
allure c'est celle une ville est perdus
c'est pas possible
et moi j'entends c'est oui mais c'est l'
assassiner en vue la sas il est
peut-être un peu de découragement voire
me disent que j'ai des goûts de 20 ans d
on a l'impression que c'est pas
quelqu'un qui sait quelques bouffées par
sihem un peu cette ville et peut-être
qu'ils étirent peu désespéré peut-être
toujours été de se lancer dès l'été
parce qu'elle a des incidences tout de
suite
cette ville est perdus c'est une dame de
85 ans que j'ai vu hier dans le square
convient de voir derrière qui m'a dit
les neveux m'ont appelé et les né à
trappes
il faut que je déménage ils m'ont dit
mais qu'elle voulut fille mais bougez
pas brûler pas solange c'est les
éducateurs de la paroisse les dux p la
paroisse qui disent donc ça sert à rien
de ce qu'on fait c'est une instit qui
faisait un instit depuis 14 ans à
trappes
et qui dit mais mais mais c'est c'est
humiliant d'entendre que notre ville ait
perdu alors que je joue à l'âge je
préfère j'espère que cette formule lui a
échappé sous le coup de la tristesse et
du découragement
toujours est il qu'il faudrait qu'il
dise vite autre chose parce que c'est
terrible pour une ville d'avoir une vue
formules comme ça je pense que ce qu'ont
en commun c'est justement de voir
qu'elle est pas perdu et que deux jours
après jours chacun d'entre nous avec son
angle on essaye de faire en sorte que
l'espérance qu'un avenir est ouvert -
ligne est un philosophe qui m'habite
peut-être que marie-laure à lui un peu
qu'ils aient emmanuel mounier qu'est le
personnalisme chrétien personnel du
personnalisme et qui a cette formule
pour moi que mais depuis une semaine qui
m'habite qui dit désespéré d'un homme
c'est le désespéré et moi j'en suis sûr
désespéré d'une ville devrait conduire
sur les rives de la désespérance
or je pense que tous ceux qui seront en
visio autres se qualifie en commun de
2,2 de faire en sorte de mettre leur
énergie pour sailly mieux c'est-à-dire
qu'il y ait des ponts c'est à dire
consentante c'est à dire qu'on se parle
c'est à dire aussi qu'on se dise la
vérité quand ça cloche il le faut il le
faut sinon le corps social va pas se
déliter et ça je le souhaite pas dans
cette ville alors on va parler avec vous
de l'action que vous menez peut-être
naïve et à roanne
justement vous êtes très à l'écouté
des habitants de certains habitants des
aime tant que souvent des difficultés
aussi
qu'est-ce qui vous disent qu'ils
reconnaissent pas qu'ils ne
reconnaissent pas les propos qu'ils
comprennent pas mais que tout ça en fait
ça ne touche pas autant que que le maire
tout le monde et j'ai beaucoup
d'inquiétude autour du maire dans le
sens source dit ban ou à la rigueur
c'est l'image que les gens voient de
trappes mais reste l'image que les gens
voient l'essentiel c'est ce que nous
envient de l'intérieur on est heureux on
se nomme mais ce qui les touche c'est
vraiment la tacc l'attaquent au maire de
la ville qui lui ont sauf que maintenant
ça prend des portes tension chez vie
moralement ou motta mentalement parce
que y
on sait qu'il aime de deviner qui ce
bail qu'il fait des choses on arrive à
faire la part des deux on se dit m quoi
qu'il arrive on a l'habitude
en fait pendant toutes les périodes
politiques on a toujours été attaqués
donc les médias on sait que ça va être
un temps et puis ça va s'arrêter
on a la sagesse de la patience on sait
très bien comment sens entre nous aussi
très bien aussi la réalité de ce qui
entre nous les musulmans savent très
bien que il ya plusieurs courants que
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure même
avec mon propre fils on lit cela en fait
en réalité une réalité on n'en parle pas
entre nous on parle pas de notre
religion et c'est vraiment on parle pas
bien religieux entre nous c'est pas du
tout un problème c'est 20 tables on voit
que les gens différemment on va tous les
gens portent leur islam différemment il
ya des femmes leur religion sans que ça
se voit par le foulard moi je le porte
de cette façon il y en a qui porte une
autre main sourire dès qu'il porte avec
tout en noir n'en font pas pas de la
religion parle de l'essentiel nous
parlent de nos enfants et c'est vrai
qu'actuellement parle beaucoup de ce qui
se passe
moi je voulais tenait à témoigner je ne
stresse par rapport au café par exemple
une maman que je classe il y à pas lent
qu'on le dit la première chose qu à
mahdia me dire que le café les femmes
qui font pas j'ai été surprise et je
pense que réellement à force d'entendre
que les funny groupement mois jacqueline
à jean macé donc j'ai pas ce qu'a fait
elle m'a dit mais si monsieur dit et
demeure une paille à café il veut lui
prouver que je m'élève qu'il a dans ce
café boire un verre et parce que danger
des baisses de diabète
shihri d'ancenis pour pouvoir j'étais
surprise je me suis dit mais c'est
dommage que celles qui tombent sur ce
témoignage
entre ce qu'on dit ce qu'on voit de
l'extérieur est-ce qu'il ya réellement
de l'intérieur c'est pas du tout la même
chose s'est elle sont elles sont plus
atteindre pour ce qui se passe voilà en
tant que pour le maire dé pour on n'est
pas inquiet l'un d'eux de ce maudit
parce qu'on est vraiment heureux et quoi
qu'il arrive on continue à être heureux
et voilà pour la part de ce que
j'entends des personnes que je croise
nouradine sur ce voilà justement alors
on a beaucoup parlé voilà avec coiffeurs
des cafés c'est des choses qui est ce
qu'il faut il faut dire ça n'existe pas
ou s'il ya quand même parfois des
tendances ou baiia la mixité n'existe
pas forcément à la caisse il alors je
souris pardon je sais que la thématique
est très sérieuse mais ce qui me fait
sourire par je suis bien obligée
d'aborder ce n'est pas c'est pas une
question qui me passionne des baux non
pas du tout vous avez mal interpréter
vos propos prête pas trop ce qui me fait
sourire c'est que ça me fait remonter
toute la séquence médiatique
oui qui s'est passé autour de ces sujets
précis partons si on refaire rapidement
l'histoire donc didier lemaire qui est
interrogé par lepoint le 5 février
didier lemaire est professeur de
philosophie depuis longtemps à trappes
donc ils vivre un témoignage à cette
journaliste du point d'accord et il
avait aussi été interviewée par une
journaliste néerlandaise avec avec son
ouvrage qui a été fait fin décembre nous
vous patrice qui est journaliste
les journalistes de tv 70 et sur la
liste normalement qui ont une formation
savent que 1 témoigne un témoignage
n'est pas une information
vous me corriger si j'ai tort un
témoignage est un témoignage
ensuite le rôle du journaliste c'est de
vérifier les informations pour ensuite
valider la formation
nous sommes d'accord mais le ces de
problème avec la sphère que nous avons
vécu c'est que didier lemaire a fait
plusieurs fois
attention je suis en train de remettre
en cause que didier lemaire soyons bon
soyons clairs je en train de parler du
processus journalistique donc dj le
maire s'est exprimé sans contradiction
pendant deux trois ou quatre jours et
c'est seulement maintenant d'ailleurs
j'étais invité sur bfm tv là j'ai planté
bfm pour revenir sur tvt 78 en version 5
il faut impérativement de la mérantaise
ses batteries c'est seulement en
maintenant qu'on s'interroge sur le fait
de savoir s'il ya des cafés qui
acceptent les femmes s'il ya des tiens
et si on s'intéresse à valider sa fin
les brigands qui ont été tenus donc
voilà ça c'était juste sur le côté sur
le côté à journalistique maintenant
revenons sur les points qui ont été
abordés lors la première chose c'est que
dj le maire a été menacée que ça sans
ambiguïté il faut une condamnation
unanime
voilà sans tergiverser sans dire de
m'aimer mais je ne sais quoi ensuite on
peut rentrer dans les propos qui ont été
tenus par didier lemaire je suis
d'accord avec le père etienne guillet
c'est dommage qu'ils disent que la ville
ait perdu parce que s'il était retournée
ou si elle retourne au lycée de la
plaine 2 nov
ça va être difficile pour lui d'être
devant des élèves qu'ils estiment perdu
mais bon ensuite sur les points que vous
avez abordé par exemple les cafés moi je
pense que les cafés déjà généralement à
part les cafés parisiens
peut-être que vous connaissez déjà
patrice c'est pas des lieux forcément de
mixité à la base soyons honnêtes dans
les cafés vous allez voir je vais
souvent voir la grand mère de la femme
qui en normandie quand on passe devant
les cafés n'y a pas une femme qui
traînent dans un café mais c'est quelle
interprétation on va donner de ceux-là
voilà en tout cas dans les cafés les
femmes peuvent y est entré elles n'y
sont pas majoritaires elles sont
minoritaires ça c'est clair et net
mais est ce qu'il ya un ballon qui dit
interdit aux femmes ou est ce qu'il ya
des femmes qui s'interdisent d'y aller
parce qu'elles ont peur de critiques ou
de pression ça c'est une réalité
la nièce est vraiment être voilà parce
que ceux qui vont nier ça c'est ce
qu'ils ont peur qu'on dise ou que s'ils
disent justement non il n'y a pas de
problème
si j'ai eu si j'accepte de dire qui a
des petits problèmes de mixité ah bah ça
veut dire que la ville est aux mains des
islamistes et que tous les cafés sont
tenus par des islamistes et que voilà
ouais c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure au niveau de la nuance qui peut
avoir qui n'existe plus dans le débat
actuel
voilà c'est soit vous êtes vous avez
essayé d'apporter de la nuance même
quand il ya des actes terroristes pour
expliquer un petit peu et comprendre
maintenant si vous essayez d'expliquer
le comprendre pourquoi des gens prennent
des qualifs next-up pour tirer sur des
terrasses ce qui me semble la moindre
des choses quand même de comprendre
pourquoi gamin on arrive là ah ben non
vous êtes un islamo gauchiste ou êtes à
l'islam aux collabos ou je ne sais quand
je ne sais quoi et tant qu'on n'arrivera
pas et d'ailleurs l'émission vous êtes
en train de faire patrie je pense que
c'est ce que vous avez voulu faire tant
qu on essayera pas d'essayer d'apporter
un peu de nuance dans ce qu'on fait sans
cacher aucun problème ben ça servira à
rien oui il faudrait réussir à décoller
les étiquettes ce serait quand même oui
mais là je dirai juste qu'il faut
toujours distinguer en fait excuser et
comprendre moi je me rappelle j'avais ma
petite fille elle me disait ça un jour
jeudi intel il a fait 6 mai tu cherche à
comprendre il m'a embêté maintenant je
sais simplement de devoir 12 la personne
parle je crois que ça c'est dans le
wimax est vraiment fondamental je pense
que ça a commencé comme ça donc voilà ma
sinon j'ai autre chose à dire sur le
café des merisiers je peux dire est une
toute petite idée sur les riziers il se
trouve qu'on a organisé un débat donc au
café des merisiers au nom de notre
petite association d'y réagir en février
l'année dernière sur la question donc de
la littérature féminine en islam
on a invité hasna hussein est en fait le
café est tenu par une femme parce que
les gens ne le savent pas la
propriétaire est une femme et elle est
demandeuse qu'on fasse des débats dans
son café
je voulais le dire parce que ça va à
l'encontre de ce qu'on entend
je crois que je suis assez d'accord avec
ce que vient de dire nouradine ceci
étant moi je passe devant ce qu'a fait
plusieurs fois par semaine lorsque la
miss pop est juste à côté et quand je
vais à la poste par exemple je passe
devant ce qu'a fait alors maintenant il
est fermé évidemment à cause du coup
c'est une autre question
mais j'y suis pas je suis passé devant
pendant plusieurs années il était ouvert
et c'est vrai que je ne vois en toute
objectivité je ne vois pas beaucoup de
femmes il faut il faut dire les choses
aussi lommel son il ya très peu de
femmes dans ce café il faut aussi dire
les choses comme elles sont alors après
je pense que certaines femmes encore une
fois je ne généralise pas mais certaines
femmes ne s'autorise pas à y aller et
certaines femmes se sentent sous
pression parce que si on les voit dans
ce café ces images qu'on nomme met en
scène et ça c'est très important ce que
vous dites parce que y'a il ya en effet
peut-être pas des dd ce qu'on appelle
des idéologies qui existent peut-être
mais il ya aussi la pression sociale
très forte ce qui est autre chose et
encore une fois il faut dire les choses
avec finesse il faut dire certaines
familles il faudra lire toutes les
femmes qu'elles soient j'aurais
effectivement j'ai déjà vu des femmes
dans ce café voilà après en effet je
pense qu'à la campagne en particulier
les femmes elles fréquentent pas
beaucoup les cafés non plus c'est vrai
que c'est plutôt dans les grandes villes
où on voit énormément les femmes dans
les cafés de cet or c'est une réalité
aussi plus alors moi je le déplore mais
c'est une réalité aussi mais c'est vrai
qu'il peut y avoir aussi une pression
sociale
oui probablement existé ici mais moi je
travaille et ailleurs aussi un
probablement moi je suis un peu gêné
qu'on a une face depuis quelques jours
la preuve par le coiffeur là je trouve
que c'est ça confine au ridicule
finalement et surtout la préoccupation
des gens aujourd'hui à trappes c'est pas
ça nous on est avec les parents du
soutien scolaire tous les jours parce
que l'association a continué son
activité de kovy dopaco vide et la
préoccupation c'est pas ça à vendredi il
y avait des mamans qui était même pas au
courant de ce qui se passait et qui
venait avec le bulletin scolaire des
enfants en disant bah tiens regarde
valérie il a eu les félicitations et sa
voix l'a montré en vie au quotidien
c'est ça c'est à autre chose on va
parler des
d'action notamment de ce qui s'est passé
après les attendent à nice de ce qu'on a
fait mais je crois que ni la vouliez
vous vouliez prendre la parole non mais
je voudrais pas qu'on passe plus de
temps sur l'histoire du café par nancy
bout mais nike comme tout le monde on
est obligé de bloquer moi je vais dans
les cafés à paris je sens que je dérange
pas les hommes si je vais dans un café à
trappes
je vais pas dans ce café attrape déjà
parce qu'il ne l'a pas qui part j'ai pas
envie de savoir ce qu'il fait dans ce
qui a fait ce qu il partage avec ses
copains c'est pas une question de la c1
n'a rien à voir avec la religion
il faut vraiment pas vraiment pas
mélanger valérie comme tu dis tu vois
quelques femmes
mon mari vient de bretagne je vois pas
de femme pas les cafés pourra-t-on jeu
juste qu'on arrête de revenir à chaque
fois que c'est une pression c'est pas
une pression religieuse c'est vraiment
une pression sociale de ce que je disais
qu vraiment parce qu'on est en train de
rentrer dans le même jeu marie laure
c'est très bien il ya des années il ya
eu un débat elle avait dénoncé aussi
l'histoire du café
comme quoi les familles à l'est pas
aujourd'hui tant mieux si à la
découverte de la pratique n'était une
femme et qu'en fin de compte c'est une
question vraiment pas ce qu'on a vu dans
cette ville et qu'on a envie de partager
des moments les hommes qui fument et où
ces questions comment une femme a besoin
faute elle le côté gauche avec sa copine
qui arrive avec son mari d'être dans un
lieu sain avec africa trois lieux qui
nous paraît prendre et bien voilà dans
un restaurant un petit peu plus de luxe
des cafés a fait sa ba ça ne les associe
à marthe âgées entre eux on les laisse
affreux mais vraiment vraiment entre
pressions sociales et pression
religieuse c'est différent ce qu'a fait
sony va pas rien à voir avec la religion
et comme leur histoire des coiffeurs ne
faut pas conduire pendant 100 francs ça
a été prouvé
on ya bientôt deux lieux interdits aux
femmes sur trappe
et si une fois
les stations qui sont fermées peut-être
réellement même si même si la pression
ce sel peut aussi venir une pression
religieuse de deux autres survenus 12
mois si la pression sociale elle peut
venir de ça aussi
ll n'est pas une année pas de rien ça
n'y avait n'a pas nommé ses branches non
mais je comprends pas je dis que les
deux peuvent aussi se mêler parfois non
alors juste mauvais actuellement ici
vous voulez bien moi je voudrais citer
le livre de jean pierre aubin qui est
sorti récemment oui justement comment on
a laissé l'islamisme pénétrer l'école
l'éducation nationale par dont le titre
très courageux déjà parce que déjà il
est vrai peut passer sous silence
continue malheureusement justement il
est trop passer sous silence j'ai eu la
chance de lire et je conseille sa
lecture
parce qu'en fait ils dénoncent
exactement ce qui se passe dans
l'éducation nationale depuis maintenant
25 ans et que on a beaucoup de mal à
compte avoir réellement voilà mais moi
je suis là surtout pour dire ça et que
les le fait qu'on ne puisse pas
justement facilement dialoguer avec avec
les élèves aujourd'hui comme je
l'expliquais c'est vraiment un problème
et le fait qu'un professeur de
philosophie soit menacée comme dit
justement un noureddine séquence qui
fait qu'on est réuni ici et moi je
voudrais d'abord revenir à ça parce que
je crois qu'il ya un vrai problème
même si l'espérance dont parlement
voisin
je la trouve formidable et c'est vrai
oui mais justement il parle aussi de vos
actions auront alors besoin peut-être
vous vous vous lanciez l'analyse est
juste après les attentats de nice voilà
parce que justement je pense que
s'articule bien ce qu'on est en train de
se dire après les attentats de nice
voilà des chrétiens qui peut te ment
innocent tue pas c'est là qu'ils
priaient dans leurs églises qui sont
mises à morts dans une église droit
droit chemin de vie brisée qui n'avaient
rien à voir juste qui faisait escale
dans une église pour se poser au mieux
de leurs semelles et le c'était
tellement dur tellement scandaleux que
la municipalité a proposé qu'on ait un
temps pour se poser pour se parler
j'étais plutôt heureux de cette
proposition parce que je me dis voilà
aussi une paroisse est les deux à
vraiment dans une démarche de dialogue
avec avec tout ce temps là juste après
la messe de la toussaint
le conseil municipal est venu et puis on
avait invité tous les représentants des
différents cultes les quelques amis
juifs de la ville sont venus les
orthodoxes sont venus la communauté
musulmane est venu les responsables des
grandes des grandes mosquées sont venus
et ensemble symboliquement on a planté
un olivier sur la place de l'église
mais en faisant cela moi je les dis un
peu un peu clairement c'est facile de
planter un olivier voilà il meurt
l'affairé fait là mais il fallait qu'il
pousse cet olivier l'objectif c'est
qu'il pousse c'est qu'il pousse et à
chaque pelletée terre que les uns les
autres mettaient certains étaient là
c'était finalement une pelletée
d'engagement d'engagement des de façon
un peu concrètes pour programme qu'on
soit uniquement dans la dimension de
symboles qui seraient sinon un peu hors
sol est un peu facile finalement ça se
rassurait pour pas trop cher alors
concrètement mais voilà nous à
l'occasion de cet arbre planté cet arbre
de la paix plantes et moi j'ai redit aux
amis musulmans aux amis juifs que notre
paroisse et on va le faire des clous que
vide pas laisser tranquille la paroisse
était vraiment
disposés à vivre quelques grands moments
j'ordonne quelques-uns un match de foot
avec la grande mosquée normalement entre
les enfants de la paroisse et les
enfants de la mosquée garçons et filles
et garçons et filles maladie il faut
continuer ça me convient très bien
parce que dans la presse que le coc vide
est arrivé là où bon jour on le fera
ferait il n'y a pas eu de débat on verra
ce qu'il en discutera mais c'est
justement là que ça devient intéressant
parce que l'espérance c'est pas au sol
l'espérance c'est pas ça s'appelle avoir
une position et puisse à moment ou si on
peut se frotter aussi on a également le
désir de reprendre nos marques qu'on
faisait juifs musulmans et chrétiens qui
nous permettait en marchant le tour du
lac de saint quentin de se parler on
prenait un thème et on se dit on se
parle un tour de lac ensemble voilà on
s'écoute -selon le grand le lac de st
gall et donc on se parle on se parle
mais on s'écoute
voilà donc en espagne c'était aussi mon
je le dis et je le redis parce que ce
que j'ai dit publiquement l'occasion de
redire aussi aux amis des autres
confessions que pour nous les chrétiens
il y avait deux points un peu
d'attention fort pour ces moments de
rencontre on s'était pas voir que les
cadres des mosquées ou des confessions
parce que sinon il ya toujours un risque
un peu d'être dans la représentation
mais nous on vous voulez si le corps de
la paroisse 6 et 50 personnes venaient
on voulait voir aussi le corps de la
communauté et ses rencontres avec leïla
on a fait déjà pas mal de choses
ensemble
mais c'est ça la logique c'est que
vraiment les habitants se rencontrent et
le deuxième point moi j'aurais dit moi
ça commence à me déranger parce que
quand on fait telle ou telle initiative
nous on arrive de façon mixte et puis en
face quelques des sommes quasiment sauf
une ou deux choses qu'on a fait avec
nayla mais très souvent il y avait des
amis gérer pour nous être en mixité
hommes femmes n'est pas quelque chose
qui nous met mal à l'aise qui est vrai
qu'on ne respecterait pas une femme
quand on part marcher ensemble ils se
parlent et sur le coeur de nos vies de
croyants et de citoyens il n'ya rien
d'indigné on respectera promis et c'est
sur le statut de la femme donc voilà et
alors c'est pas évident donc une
certaine en tickets et bien pour moi
c'est aussi ma responsabilité de curé
dans une ville comme ça de pouvoir dire
que l'égalité entre l'homme et la femme
pouvait très bien se déployer dans des
façons de vivre un petit peu différente
mais tout de même que chacun a accès à
la parole que chacun a accès
une livre décision et que ça peut pas
être dissymétrique c'est aussi ça vivre
en france voilà comme je les dis je n'ai
pas dit en plantant olivier mais je leur
dis souvent des amis musulmans dans la
ville de trappes pas je ne suis pas
d'accord pour que hommes et femmes de se
serre pas la main
voilà je pense que ça fait partie des
marqueurs républicain c'est de la
république voilà c'est dit et c'est à
discuter dans notre ville elle est très
discuté de c est leur problème me sens
moi c'est une des choses importantes où
on se serre la main et en saut et moi je
le redis en serrant la main il n'y a
rien à dire je vous promet de respecter
votre épouse votre main de dieu voilà il
n'y a pas de questions là dessus
voilà donc voilà ouais je sais très bien
qu'en disant cela certains étaient à
terre tandis que ça allait mais c'est
aussi ça je pense ou où il faut qu'on
puisse se redire vivre ensemble ça passe
par des choses importantes qui sont qui
sont souvent la dq quincy et dans le
respect dans notre pays et serge geyer
probablement sur les sur les enfants
peut être sur les nerfs ça vient sous
les rires de l'image qu'on donne aussi
aux enfants elle est importante wissam
ans j'en suis je suis directrice d'une
structure sociale je suis pas directeur
je suis une femme donc là aussi je pense
que pour les enfants qu'on accueille à
trappes
c'est important aussi de se dire que
c'est une femme elle peut prétendre à ce
type de à ce type de fonction et que ça
pose pas de problème
d'ailleurs dans le temps les risques
pardon je vais acheter au juste mais
dans ce débat il ya deux hommes n'aura
delpérier et 3 fabre et je suis très
content qu'ils aient trois femmes qui
participent à cette émission
et moi je suis très contente
bon il se trouve que je suis une femme
et je n'ai pas choisi mais je trouve que
ces hausses a aussi du sens au sein de
l'association et 7 apporte émission on
en saura peut-être avec leïla puisque
son association s'appelle les moments de
coeur mais c'est moi qu'ils y des femmes
très important où ils sont allés dans
une ville comme tout à fait alors nous
on accueille beaucoup plus de mamans que
deux papas évidemment vous le racontez
nous un peu mr justement alors là les
spots combien 40 49 ans de carnet pour
présentera ça fait 42 ans il ya une
quarantaine de personnes de nationalités
différentes qui fréquentent la misère
quand il me dit ça c'est compliqué de
faire vivre une ville aussi avec 40
nationalités différer la la spécificité
un peu de cette de cette association
c'est qu'elle est née en fait deux alors
c'est oui j'étais là par iliad éclatent
à l'inalco l'indicé des protestants six
interpellations des paroisses
protestantes du secteur et elle s'est
constituée finalement cette association
avec des protestants avec des
catholiques avec une mairie communiste
qui est quand même assez atypique
et peut-être ça me touche c'est
intéressant et donc ça fait 40 ans que
oui mais en terre voilà ça fait 40 ans
que cette plate ou par exemple 40 ans
qu'elle essaye d'être au service des
habitants de trappes et dans un esprit
justement de fraternité beaucoup plus
que de 2
d'efficacité j'ai envie de dire le
projet de base de la miss pop c'est
plutôt de vivre la fraternité avec les
habitants et les activités elles sont au
service quelque part de cette de cette
fraternité c'est ce sont des prétextes
en fait pour moi
l'idée c'est le prétexte ça veut dire 7
d'alphabétisation
c'est du soutien scolaire après ces deux
ans de l'alphabétisation pour cent
soixante dix adultes alors pas en ce
moment malheureusement parce qu'avec le
coc vide on n'a pas pu reprendre des
activités avec les adultes mais en tout
cas en temps normal en accueille 170
adultes à la fois pour des cours de
français et pour ce qu'on appelle de la
des ateliers sociolinguistique donc dans
sociolinguistique il ya la langue et il
ya l'aspect social aussi donc tout
l'aspect citoyenneté aussi sur lequel on
travaille on accueille 90 enfants donc
là on a toujours les 90 enfants depuis
la rentrée de septembre on n'a pas
arrêté les activités avec des parents
qui nous font vraiment confiance et des
enfants qui viennent de différents
horizons on a des enfants qui sont
d'origine maghrébine des enfants qui
sont d'origine africaine sri lanka inde
exit aussi et des asiatiques aussi et
tout ce petit monde l'a finalement vie
plutôt plutôt bien ensemble ça se passe
ça se passe plutôt bien
et puis pendant les vacances scolaires
on a aussi des activités à destination
des jeunes cet été nous radine pourra
témoigner puisqu'il était présent on a
fait tout un travail sur justement
l'éducation aux médias parce que c'est
quelque chose c'est quelque chose qui
est à mon avis très intéressant les
jeunes se
se focalise sur des choses qui sont
immédiatement les réseaux sociaux
youtube pour eux c'est là c'est la
réalité et il faut décortiquer tout ça
il faut les aider à à pratiquer la fois
parce qu'elles sont les sources
d'information sont encore mais sur une
attaque qui importe quoi ton problème
est ce qu'il est vraiment vérifié
important et je pense que les
associations de trappes c'est la même
chose pour la selle et puis pour
d'autres encore elles font ce travail au
quotidien et ça malheureusement ce
monsieur morandini il vient pas non mais
quand les dans les associations pendant
trois heures pour voir ce qui s'y passe
vraiment et c'est dommage alors dès
qu'il a justement elle est maman du
coeur quelles sont vos actions d'addax
nos actions c'est d'abord que on
travaille avec les jeunes du quartier et
d'ailleurs et c'est ouvert aux autres
villes à la citoyenneté
ça veut dire partager des moments
ensemble se rend compte de nos
problématiques arrêter de se victimiser
en disant voilà l'état ne fait rien pour
nous mais en attendant si on attend
après l'état mais qu'est ce que nous on
doit faire de notre côté donc on ont
fait du ramassage dans les quartiers ont
fait du média comme aussi avec nos
racines
par exemple on a utilisé le fait que les
jeunes l'ont été dans les hôtels sociaux
s'occuper des personnes en difficulté
ils ont tout de suite dit menaïl assez
difficile de donner un adulte on est mal
à l'aise parce que défendre à dire non
par exemple quand une maman veut prendre
des mois les trois paquets de yaourt au
lieu de deux et on doit penser aux
audois en même temps c'est un habitant
de la dir nord donc du coût de nos
débuts l'idée de se dire apprenez à les
connaître autrement va les faire
témoigner sur sur leur parcours de vie
comment ils sont venus en france et
ensuite vous verrez que ce sera il y
aura une relation autres et puis vu au
raparou dessus en dessous ensemble et
pas qu'ils ont réellement réaliser leur
parcours de vie m'ont dit on des héros
c'est des personnes qui on sent que on
n'est plus au dessus d'eux ils sont
vraiment eux au dessus news nous nous
sommes dans un moment difficile et du
partage ans mon coeur me dit que saab
est à la base quand on disait quand des
shs alpaguer déjeuner dans
dans nos villes et en fait ils ont
utilisé le fait qu' il pouvait aller
sauver le monde
ailleurs des difficultés et ben moi je
dis aux jeunes la voyez on peut trouver
des fleurs notre voisin quand nos
voisins on a des gens qui sont en
difficulté leur dire que des semaines
que voilà la france ne nous accepte pas
venez avec nous regardez la france ne
nous accepte pas mais vous êtes français
c'est à vous de construire la france
françois des choses autour de chez vous
donc voilà il est vraiment l'association
dont les mamans faut pour masquer la
mixité
on entend de maman du earth est ce qu'on
doit porter l'association comme mort
d'un enfant il apprend aussi d'avoir la
sensibilité d'une d'une femme
il sait pas inné en lui on est différent
les hommes ont des choses que en tout
cas c'est une sensibilité l'autre font
qu'on est tous maman du coeur cédera
unix
mais pas imaginer mais ici voilà je
voulais des marqueurs cinq ans comme on
attend vraiment du coeur qui ont 80 et
hommes et femmes et de toutes
confessions voilà justement vous vous
parliez juste de 2,2 grâce aux femmes
vous avez aussi pu faire parler des
hommes voudraient en un mot vous nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé au forum
mondial de la paix grâce à lui oui j'ai
accompagné de dés des mamans qui sont
deux des familles qui sont déchirés dans
leur chair parce qu'on a des familles
qui sont voilà qui ont leurs enfants
fait le choix de partir enfin il était
dans un âge
aucun d'eux n'avait pas plus de 22 ans
enfin si il y en avait qui étaient âgés
mais ils ont fait ce choix de partir et
donc la douleur de ces mamans il fallait
bien un endroit pour qu'elle se trouve à
parler entre elles parce que par
quelques combats avant de partir en
syrie un de partir d'une série et du
coup j'ai comme je travaille avec
l'association initiatives et changement
avec aussi on fait avec qui on fait des
ateliers laïcité info intox sur les
médias donc avec non pas les riches suis
content de découvrir en fin de compte
mais ça m'étonne pas du tout tourné dans
le même combat est la même
lyon et on en a on a vu comment
travailler au mieux avec nos jeunes et
du coup on a été au forum mondial pour
la paix parce que ces mamans ont pu
raconter leurs histoires à des lycéens à
des collégiens chose qu'on n'a pas pu
faire à trappes
malheureusement parce que c'était pas
écouter avant l'arrivée de monsieur
rabais c'était un sujet tabou donc au
mois de novembre on a pu le faire on a
pu aller c'était plus t'as pas
personnellement un c'est moi j'étais
beaucoup contacté par des associations
de l'extérieur ou des sociologues qu'on
ne pouvait pas faire ce travail
autre que par mois parce que c'est
compliqué d'accéder au lycée d'accéder à
des choses bref on était au forum de là
ils ont pu lui raconter leur histoire et
j'ai vu comme les enfants ont compris
les premières 2 et des enfants s'étaient
c'est maman parce que c'est maman qui
témoigne ce départ est une détresse et
que du coup un arrachement pour eux et
les prêts conséquences de ce départ pour
la france déjà à travers s'il ya des
attentes à bhl sahara en france mon bas
c'est pas les départs mais c'est ce
qu'ils sont radicalisés en france mais
en tout cas les rebelles sont là et
c'est les mamans qui peuvent nous dire
pourquoi justement il faut faire
attention et j'ai découvert qu'un papa
c'est plus dur pour les hommes de parler
vous savez ils se retrouveront après la
prennent le temps de parler mais les
hommes ont vécu ici cette douleur
d'avoir des enfants partis c'est très
compliqué pour eux parce que un homme là
une fierté il va montrer ses émotions à
son copain une maman un peu plus facile
si elle trouve une personne qui n'a pu
contrôler son émotion flore et de
traquer et moi j'ai vu qu'à ce forum au
moins il n'y a pas qu'à venir il a
raconté son histoire racontée la douleur
d'avoir des petits enfants sur le
territoire et il a pu craquer ils
mettent des mots et maux et d'avoir
réussi
à voir cette situation qu'un homme ici
parce que tout le monde en sort on est
beaucoup à souffrir que par les médias
c'est dur de le retenir bah écoutes je
sais que tu le vis d'empêcher à jamais
pour vous par un peu naïve nayla pardon
de tout ça il nous reste plus beaucoup
de temps et jean-jacques on donne une
conclusion à cette émission
donner la parole de chacun valérie c'est
quoi vos espoirs aujourd'hui pour cette
ville les espoirs pour cette ville pour
moi c'est les jeunes en fait parce que
je sens qu'ils sont qu'ils ont envie de
réussir comme tous les jeunes qui porte
cet espoir-là de réussite au delà de
de l'identité qu'on leur colle parfois
donc oui mon espérance et les jeunes les
enfants et l action que vous faites est
importante
évidemment vis-à-vis d'eux berrier qu'il
reste bien vivant des plateformes de
rencontres des lieux on se rend compte
qu'on se voie postale et où on vit
ensemble on vit ensemble et si chacun
est essentielle et inde était blême ça
peut-être
il ya eu aussi il ya des communautés ya
un fort de 45 60 communautés ray et bien
que caen et qu'il y ait des lieux dans
la vie sociale où l'on se rencontre dans
la diversité et où l'on vive au fil de
l'année ensemble
le pire serait que chacun se rapatrie
chez soi et là ça ce serait la
catastrophe
voilà je ne crois pas ça si on s'y
engage ils vous feront encore marie leur
signal moi je dirai au niveau de l'école
sûrement multiplier les lieux de
dialogue dans un temps obligatoire entre
guillemets pour que le pour que le
dialogue puisse s'instaurer justement
et puis sinon je crois qu'il faut aussi
redonner du sens au mot refusez donc
l'anathème entre islamophobie des
contrôles dès qu'on ose parler de
l'islam et qu'on n'est pas musulman on
est traité d' islamophobie c'est pas les
musulmans
voilà et donc je pense que c'est dommage
parce que moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce
qu'a dit nayla quand elle dit il y a
plusieurs islam
on est tous différents au sein de
l'islam donc il faut aussi accepter que
ceux qui parlent de l'islam ils ont le
droit d'en parler pour dénoncer les
hélas les les dérives vers l'islamisme
et que c'est pas pour ça qu'on est
islamophobe donc donc je reprendrai la
formule de camus il faut justement que
les mots ne pas rajouter au mot le
parlent par des mots qui ne sont pas les
bons ne pas ne pas dire les bonbons
c'est rajouter du malheur
noureddine évidemment il
tout ça se déroule aussi sous fond un
peu politique puisqu'il ya eu abus y
aura peut-être une annulation des
élections
donc on voit bien que
éval par exemple le maire essaye de
tirer un peu profit de cette situation
est ce que ça joue ça aussi oh comme
vous y allez le maire essaie de tirer
profit c'est peut-être bête donc je sais
pas participer à des émissions comme ça
un peu sensationnaliste alors justement
parce que si on revient patrice j'étais
intervenu dans un club de la presse il
ya quelques règles quelques temps déjà
pendant le pas loin des élections
municipales de trappes et puis j'avais
dit oui les frais c'est la première fois
que je vois des municipales aussi
violente avec des insultes des anathèmes
avec des des rumeurs sur des candidats
etc etc
monté en épingle et je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce que ça va laisser comme trace
c'est là que je me posais dans la ville
et puis ensuite dans voilà dans la
gouvernance de la ville
ben quelques quelques mois plus tard
avec le recours notamment d'hotman nasri
qui est conseiller municipal
d'opposition recours qui du coup a été
acceptée et puis ensuite avec la
décision du tribunal administratif de
rendre inéligible le maire et d'annuler
les élections là y'a un recours au
conseil d'état vient de ça donne c'est
tourner le panneau ça en fait
voilà c'est ça sera en appel tout ça
pour moi c'est la suite logique de tout
cette bataille politique qui a eu lieu
aux municipales vous me direz ce sont
deux jeunes candidats
ils sont jeunes peut-être que la
jeunesse voilà a les défauts de
l'outrance c'est ce qu'on a vu
certainement dans cette danse et
municipales à trappes et qu'on en voit
encore les stigmates
ensuite pour revenir sur ce que vous
disais tout à l'heure par rapport au
maire de trappes bon le maire de trappes
s'est trouvée c'est ce que j'ai comme
analyse en tout cas à mon avis coincé
entre deux injonctions contradictoires
un devoir condamner fermement d'ailleurs
il a dit lui-même qu'il avait appelé la
préfecture pour faire bénéficier le
maire de la protection sections dont
vraiment insisté sur le fait qu'il
fallait protéger deux formes et qu'il
était
et qu'il était vraiment inconcevable
qu'ils étaient menaces de mort juste
pour une opinion et de l'autre côté être
également obligé de répondre à tout ce
qui avait été dit par ce même didier
lemaire vrai que c'est compliqué un peu
coincé peut être maladroitement parfois
en ayant l'impression qu'il était en
train de dénigrer le professeur lui-même
est en train dans un contexte on le
rappelle la patrie ce contexte à vue
elle pâtissait le 16 octobre c'est pas
loin donc dans ce contexte là on peut
comprendre que l'opinion publique ait pu
aussi se retourner contre le maire de
trappes en disant mais attendez il ya un
prof qui est menacée avec ce qui s'est
passé à quelques mois et lille ose
remettre en cause leurs obligés de vous
interrompre d'euralille parce que les
missions à redon
l'émission est terminée et et b ça
prouve que voilà il ya encore beaucoup
de sujets qu'on aura abordé sur cette
ville je vous remercie infiniment tous
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
night and day one
merci bien sûr nous a dit merci jd mais
xie pardon merci marie laure segal et
merci valérie rodrigues et à très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de page j'espère
qu'on a fait un peu le tout voilà on a
dit des choses en tout cas merci à tous
[Musique]